I can recall that Playboy article coming
out and people come up to me and said
have you seen playboy it says he's done
it he did it it The Dude's my detector
says he's he's done it it's got to be a
damaging thing what happened with that
lie-detector test
well first I think he'd have to start
with a Playboy MD was I had the two
interviews with him now if this pose had
when I had the first one here right
right where I'm at now and that was more
such a sensible interview there was no
where would I call him that questions
and but after I escaped and come back
and they returned the original Arthur I
think his name's mckinley james mchenry
and he had a senior editor gonzales with
him
and that's when he started winging up
the lie-detector I know it and asking
what I considered that question you know
about would you kill a guardian a
petulant is most difficult answer that
type of poisons but anyway I agreed to
take a lie-detector test
on the grounds know everything I'm
telling now is on tape with Playboy on
the grounds that I mean providing that
they would take at the same time to
Committee date because I didn't promise
the committee I take one but before I
took when I was going to do some
research on read up on just like it
would psychiatry anything else but they
wanted to test before the twenty got it
so uh apparently Kershaw he agreed to it
they came down here and at that time I
was no on and and they gave me a test
now I don't want make excuses for
because he do something dumb I don't
like come up excuses but there are
certain things that shouldn't I learnt
later the shouldn't of a condition I
shouldn't have took the test on Francis
we interrupted frequently in this it was
hot in the room and all that and all
that your blood pressure and things
but I think the main you have headaches
to it or some mention that you were
taking aspirin and I don't know whether
that affects your thirst or not you know
that that's not supposed to affect the
only thing affects it is um
interruptions because interruptions are
only your blood pressure and a hot room
now I read the text of the company put
it out read John readeth and heels and
uh there's a lot of uh they use a lot of
buzz stratagem I guess you'd call it
wouldn't you wish you hadn't have taken
it uh well not particular I think I
after reading the books I don't think
that at first initially I thought was
going to be damaging but after a riddle
I read for Pollock we have folks and it
didn't seem all that damaging because
it's not all that exact and once you
read a book you can't beat the test but
you can keep them from beating you for
instance you can learn how to breathe
normal things like that and so the
conditions have a lot to do with it and
you don't felt I feel that those
conditions were particularly good at
that time for for that particular test
no but I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't
discredit testing on the condition on
those conditions otherwise I suspect
read would the polygraph firm from I
think
now where I made a mistake on like the
mess is not reading the text because
once you read any more comfortable you
know how to how to react and what to
expect I guess
well you just more comfortable you know
how the machine operates mm-hmm and they
will you take another one who has just
turn you off lie detector no I'm gonna
take one of the committee actually but
I'm going to go into more depth for the
committee for instance I think there's
been allegations without Mason king
prison all that and Kenny Noah well I'm
gonna have well two questions with me if
I ever having a relaxed recollection of
ever mission mission either button until
I was rested and apart be uh I think
it's not allegation not to which you
rant about your answer those questions
would be that that you had not yeah and
no rec Lex no the story says there's a
line where playboy says you know you're
a liar and you say yes I know that
they're true or false that's all
that's not only tapes see Kershaw made
the attorney Jack Kershaw made taste and
play ball and made names and I asked ur
sauce said did I say something like
jokingly and he called him he listened
his taping said it wasn't honor and so
on now the rest of the questions I don't
know I think they had they had except
they they might substitute he is for a
yeah for yes system like that well do
you feel damaged by the article to the
extent that you might try to file some
legal proceedings against them I did
file a suit in Niceville I mean in
Knoxville but Jack Kershaw attorney he
was suggest I would do it and I did and
I think now Mark Lane is going to sue
them and if he don't why was Jack her
sure we're totally got a lot of money
for this is that would you understand
well I know there's money involved
because there was a when they come down
the polygraph test it was messing money
but I don't know just how much I know
it's between 10 and 20,000 mm-hmm but
you don't care about the money
particularly although it had to disturb
you a little bit no I'm not concerned
about money I've never taken any money
from what concern me about is the
article and you see they had a contract
original with me it's an informal
contractor we that's mean courser would
get to censor and take out anything was
objectionable her that we thought we we
didn't say they thought we said or
something of that nature and I never did
happen they just went ahead and
published what they had what they wanted
to do so Jackie
Kershaw is out of the picture partially
because of that partially because of
these t-shirts that ticked you off
pretty good you've had 13 attorneys in
it you must wonder if there's anyone
around you gonna live with that's really
not correct
quite correct I felt attorneys uh
thought that tourneys a quarter-point on
their name spoke to for instance when
Percy Foreman he had the court appoint
two attorneys to two public defenders I
never did speak to him but of course now
they're on the record me firing actually
I never did hire more fire one attorney
two attorneys Bernard festival and James
Bazar they were they represent me seven
years they got me firing them well use
it
what a suit runs out that's it there's
no more firing well I know all these
stories it we fired 13 attorneys or
something you've studied an awfully lot
of about the law while you've been in
here as I understand you're very
studious in that particular area and it
someone mentioned to me the Tennessee
law says that when a new trial motion is
filed in the trial judge dies it's
automatically a new trial why why hasn't
that happened
let's supposed to be law and as you
mentioned a judge battle a trial judge
didn't die he died well he has to die
within a 30-day period and he died the
28th day or something we had a motion
for new trial on well a successor judge
he ruled on the the statue statute one
seven one one seven
the successor judge denied it but we
appealed it and neither the Tennessee
Court of Appeals all the Tennessee
Supreme Court recognized it so I guess
we could go in there on some type of
Parilla rid of air or something you
wanted there okay
I think most people understand now that
there was no conspiracy in the escape
that you acted on your own you said it
time and time again and I think
everybody believes you well what did you
hope to do they were dimensioned at the
trial that you wanted to break out of
prison to break into a courtroom
that's a poetic way of putting it but
that that's that's it isn't of course
the main thing he escaped in prison is
you know nicely get our attention on
that but of course I did have considered
several times if I should have been able
got out like that uh it was been
extremely difficult me to stay out long
- three months nothing I thought there
was a possibility that I can have some
intermediary contact Griffin Bell now
Griffin Bell can't give me a trail but
he can he can recommend to the courts
through some type of a friend of the
court brief or something that they act
favourable on a petition I would file
seeking a new trail but of course not
have to get that for you had you just
were frustrated you just felt nothing
was happening and then you wanted to try
to get something moving is it
I don't know frustrated right word it's
just uh there's really two things going
the escape + possibility of working out
some kind of arrangement with Belkis mr.
Bell he's mentioned several times he
wants to get this cleared up one way or
another and of course I would to one
whatever but the a lot of this has to do
with declassifying some FBI files you
feel there's a lot of suppressed
information that nobody is talking about
it well I know there's I think lolis
information has been put under seal in
Washington DC I think judge or the judge
up for federal judge Smith I believe his
name is he's a these is some SCLC
members of filed suit saying there's
personal things in there but I've
suspected the FBI or the justifier has
put a lot of things are not personal you
mean personal things involving dr. King
well others - out of other - but but I
think that's a cover
King but anyway up I wrote this SCLC
representing Philadelphia I wrote the
committee now told them was anything
their personal but as far as I was
concerned naked Joe they could destroy
it you know on forthwith long as we
could get a transcript the items in
there wasn't personal so I am her
anything committee yet but I think you
like favorite one right off well I guess
you got a stir wondering who the hell
you trust you know it's gonna be here
for sure
our movie
what do you think might be in those
those files do you have any inkling or
any idea what it was my what they might
contain I don't have any idea I know the
Church Committee come up with a bunch of
files it was damaging to the FBI and
there were things damage the maze done
been published in Time magazine
publications like that so uh I know
we're nothing near damaged it may so it
must be favorable you figure they
wouldn't mr. Pressman there was nothing
there I guess it's a theory huh
you've spent well you're in
administrative segregation here now and
we're talking about your life in prison
if we're talking about an escape I'm
sure you spend so many so many years in
solitary and has a stake it's taken a
toll do you feel that it has taken a
tremendous toll on you physically
emotionally mentally I think while
you're in there it takes a toll on you
you seem like you aids and get nervous
and but I always seem to cooperate a
couple weeks after I'm out I know I was
in three years straight one time and
have them get out their little exercise
and some like normal how do you get in
shape what do you do drink fruit juices
or is not good isn't with back exercise
no song little Sun fresh air seems to
work yes
mm-hmm then you're pretty well content
here at Brushy Mountain you certainly
don't want to go to a federal prisoner
of I heard that incorrectly I know you
have too many well first of all I'm not
a federal prisoner once they get you in
there they can keep transferring around
you maybe
boi-oi-oi-oing out one day and latter
next and use the state prison sir you
have more access to legal material
things
federal prisons got they have a good
propaganda system but that's about it
I'd rather be in just about any state
prison to federal prison you're afraid
to try to do something to you
federal well FBI they use these
informers they might throw something on
you or your sleep or something but
there's really no reason we go in the
federal prison because they tried this
two three times in 1973 I think it tried
sent me to a mental institution and
federal Springfield my Springfield
Springfield Missouri yes and you fought
that
yes I've a talent in the it's clearly
against the law we have a law that says
they can't transfer you out of state and
yes you will are they actively trying to
do that are you
not now they've stopped now but they
were trying to do it in it and while he
was trying to do it they knew it was
against the law but they figured they
could get away I suppose we're talking
with warden Lane and he was talking
about the FBI swooping in here at the
time of your escape they were after you
that's all that they were concerned
about it you you figure that the same
way don't you yes and if they found you
what do you think they would have done
do you have any idea I mean I guess what
I'm asking do you think the FBI want you
dead is what I got I don't know I don't
like make two extreme statements I know
they arrested when he escaped he and
Lane Larry hacker they beat him up
trying to make him tell them where I was
at well he didn't where I was that
anyway because when we escaped we were
in different directions but I don't know
what they wanted to do something in me
or just you know get all the glory for
bringing me in but FBI arrest that's
been going on for a long time my brother
John they got him down here 17 years and
aiding abetting a bank robbing the guy
that's supposed because pled guilty
robbing it got 18 months so on harassing
Carol back in st. Louis I understand he
burglarized her house and sister's house
this troubles you a great deal isn't it
I yes I uh
you mean all these various Erasmus they
say yeah yeah I think sconce lighting
down now because there's no one to rest
they've eat the gum in jail or alright
anybody inventions about taking your
father back to prison he'll that was
boring or guilty plea as he he'd escaped
from I wear something there was going to
hold him back back during today's in
Memphis yeah well I never did say
anything about that about a year ago
which is because the I thought they
might do it I talked to the House
Committee and they said if anyone was
arrested on not connected with the King
case but just you know harassment where
they'd considered an obstruction of
justice at least that's the way I
understood him to say okay put a little
black between everyone go on to go on to
Memphis here for a minute when you were
brought into Memphis
your attorney your attorney now Mark
Lane says that there was I think he was
using the word torture there was there
were some conditions there and in the in
the penal institution that that I'd like
to explore with you a little bit keeping
lights on all the time that kind of
thing can you describe that for me yes I
think when I came back me when they
extradite me from London yes well yes I
did have a special they called the vault
fixed up they had steel place it with
Windows and they had these TVs monitors
you two sets of them and her watch 24
hours two cards and cell block like you
would and and microphones now you can
you can discuss anything attorney
because they could pick up up on the
microphone I think
the facial said they turn the microphone
was down when attorneys come in but you
just had to take the word on that
consequently we we had to write a lot of
notes out but the people effects these
up wasn't a sheriff or state of
Tennessee was - uh - two lieutenants
from the UH from the Federal Bureau of
Prisons and of course you couldn't lie
sir on 24 hours/day you know who these
lieutenants are well they got their
names up there I know my say uh do you
think it went higher do you think of
Ramsey Clark was awfully active in that
area at that time was the did he have
anything to do with this do you think
well the Bureau of Prisons of the
Justice Department controls it but I
don't know what individual gave the
orders it could have been Carlson the
baby's head in prisons but but does else
it wasn't unhealthy place I know one
time I broke out of rice and I thought
may have been poison or something yeah I
finally got a blood test and tried to
find out what that was and then later on
about five years later when we got a
habeas corpus him we try to get to all
these blood tests and things and they
said the sheriff daughter told her
records destroyed so it's really
couldn't find these tests no hey there
Sheriff
he ordered to do it destroy the test for
some reason that's all in the record
down enemy 1974 a Peace Corp saying what
would be the motive in your mind James
do you think it was it was an attempt to
- just to wear you down physically and
mentally to get you to the point where
you'd plead guilty is what you think
that was point of it yeah I think that's
what they do they just were you down on
the grassland you get and especially for
your attorney if you or some attorneys
on your side that's it's difficult from
- were you down you know but they get
control of defense then they can more or
less maneuver into position where you
got to go along with at least temporary
mm-hmm what happened the most I think
the most
the incident getting more leeway it was
after Haynes got off the case author
Haynes the first attorney and
the trial judge told me at that time
they would in effect it wouldn't mean
there'd be no further change of counsel
so once I got Percy Foreman I couldn't
fire him if I would have fired him and
went to trial with a public defender
because he'd got the public defender in
on a case shortly after he cut in on did
you have any feelings toward dr. King at
all before this happened no that's why
I'm going to take this polygraph test
it's my contentions I've never of course
the you can my Mason presidents name or
something but if you had really strong
feelings about that you remembers I'm
going to take the polygraph test and if
I ever mentioned King's name or
Kennedy's president I think that's two
names Ben Mason up until I got a rest of
the charge when that's less after I got
a risk that I mentioned their names in
but up until then the question would be
if I ever had any recollection of
imaginer names of course if you don't
well then I think that should indicate
something so this was where Kings
activity and him he himself would like
another world and I mean you just really
had no strong feelings apparently one
way or the other I think the states the
state the contention is I used well not
state but I'm incorporated I used to see
these various political figures on TV
and Missouri and get worked up but they
didn't have TV in Missouri so that's
fictions mm-hmm
what do you think he was killed have you
given that any thought but the motive
well not too much on I don't read too
much you can't get too good of
information anyway because saying might
be misleading but I had an are clear
somewhere were in March of 1968 believe
he had changed his philosophy rather
than integration he was interesting
getting economic consideration and
course there's a lot difference between
you know warning money in the morning
going arresting or something like that
do you think he might have made some of
his own people angry at him for the
stance changed only one one wanting to
emphasize he cannot make the well I
couldn't answer that you'd have to see
these tapes and things like yeah but you
don't have a real good theory about why
he was killed in I know I'm more
concerned about I've heard all kinds of
theories about it room um I don't pay
much attention to it with something most
of them are ridiculous mm-hmm took a
long time to get fingerprints review I
think 17 days do you think they had him
and weren't telling you they had him
murdered or do you have any idea why
that was pulled wake up
I'm gonna work
this is a continuation of of part three
it took a long time to identify your
fingerprints 17 days do you feel that
some were lifted or some were planted or
do you having lots of other uh no I
don't know I can I couldn't be certain
Jim McKinley the Playboy Eddard he says
they can't let them
the only thing would make me suspicious
something being lifted I think it was
two prints found on a bear can't bear
and I sell them ever drink beer unless
it's going to tavern by one distant it's
because I'm in there but it did take
quite a lot quite a while to match the
prints up I think I suppose have
computers I think they can match them up
in there a few hours isn't sure
thirteen or fourteen days and and the
Missouri pen she certainly had them
didn't they
yeah but they had the wrong prints on a
car or something I they killed Maya ah
there was some confusion that I think so
it wasn't there's witnesses now that say
that you were at that filling station a
second and Linden you were there is it
is that your story you were at this gas
station get the tire change or repair
yes I don't have a flat tire night
before that and uh uh
one time I mentioned Percy for him try
to get tires evidence and he never did
do anything after after he got the early
player they give the tire to him kept
the car getting the tire and floor mats
and certain items either I guess I think
possibility certain things would help
substantiate my testimony mm-hmm so you
heard you heard the news on the radio
visit we were sure you were driving you
left at that gas station and second and
Linden what about six or I don't have
anyway no one I think is around that
time but I don't even know if it's
Lyndon I know that approximate air it is
and then I've seen the map on the
Enquirer
you can you were going back to to pick
up this man that you say is Raul no I
just waiting the car back and I'm the
way I've recollected I've seen some
police cars and people that are not
turned off the other way now there is
policemen's wooden placement down he
says he seaman told me to get my
so-and-so out of the area I don't have
no recollection of that but uh that
could have been soaked I don't remember
anything wasn't born I did you were
aware that that you had somebody an
associate at that rooming house that
what they call a flophouse yes
and but you you weren't going back to
pick him up necessarily you were just
gonna leave the car there yes
huh I'll go to a movie or so here well I
suppose someone yes and there's two
movies right down straight to me but
you know I don't I really don't it
doesn't take a whole lot of police
around get me to go somewhere else
they'll find out what's going on
especially for me yeah police has asked
me to begin with
so you heard all this confusion here
turned flipped on the radio they said
dr. King's been shot at that did you
think you were set up at that point I
know I was headed towards toward New
Orleans when I had radio I just keep the
radio and I think I didn't have too
strong feelings about the shooting but I
think them 50 or 20 minutes later they
mention the Mustang white and then
instead of going towards New Orleans and
make me phone calls I just turn left and
went towards Alabama well but you had a
buddy back there didn't you didn't you
think about picking him up again or
there didn't didn't that didn't that
cross your mind no I didn't cross him I
laugh worry about yourself yes mm-hmm
but you went to her toward Atlanta then
yes why Atlanta what was in Atlanta well
I had to go somewhere there's no
particular reason why I would go to
Atlanta but I had some clothing things
there oh you had a [ __ ] in there I had a
room there in Atlanta yes Oh is she
actually sure you were going back to
pick up some of that yes and then you
made a call to they should get a number
for an answering service you know New
Orleans is it
I had one yes I didn't I didn't make any
call I didn't end make a call after
seeing these it's commotion in the
street their place running around but I
never did make the call because he was
not I didn't see any phones on the road
and I heard all these reports yeah I
forgot about telephone calls yeah is it
did you feel your buddy was involved in
all this police activity here did you
you did dude you just plain wasn't my
buddy anyway
nobody just a financial right
this is the man that would give you
money yes mm-hmm this is the man that
you know is Raul yes okay
little black between there okay okay
I'll roll
when when you met Raoul you did you
didn't know any other name for him
that's the name that he said was his and
that that's all you ever knew
yeah and you met him where Canada up in
Canada and and you just met in a saloon
it was a saloon in a waterfront area of
Montreal he never became good friends
then no I wouldn't good friend just
business these are all aliases that I
assume you don't think Raul was a real
name at all then no I've got some free
of information papers nerve centers
rolls Santiago or something New Orleans
supposed to be a him but that I don't
have the FBI's material from the FBI
thought I don't have no nothing's
substantiate that but Disgaea this man
Raul was that was was the contact
between you and the money I mean that
that's where the money came from yeah
yes I guess no I mean he paid you hmm
page would like it hundred-dollar bills
or 20 inside just gave you 20 s a new
new $20 bill I don't think he's always
knew I didn't pay that much that much
attention but see at that time I thought
that was considerable amount of money
because most Maya offenses were not
quite but of course people are nor
colleagues trade or anything at that's
really a small small time is that what
you think of as Raul's prime interest as
narcotics and some gun smuggling on the
side or well that's that's what I think
course the investigators think I think
other thing but I'm just talking time
what what I thank you we're primarily he
was involved in narcotics and he seemed
to be working out of New Orleans is that
did that seem to be like his home here
home base yes so you and so you went
down to New Orleans a number of times
no only trip I ever made well I've been
through there a couple times
picking up for meeting someone the only
time I ever made a long trip I'd do it
in December of 67 I go round trip there
36 hours and that was only a special
trip ever made and you get down there
and was he and I like that did he live
like in a rooming house sure I never
didn't meet anyone in any type of
private establishment you may have got
that out some depositions and Percy
Foreman thought the only person up
wherever I met a person being a tab in a
public place I don't be very sure houses
so like tip over
yeah okay great five feet okay this
should take it that is that is just a
the mob that's the Mafia's way of pan is
in 20s that's what they always use
that's why I was curious very hey they
were they on between our bills okay but
when you get to New Orleans would would
you make a call and say Raoul I'm here
do you want to meet me someplace
what no I never did call him I think
someone else he's the answer to phone i
dimension that Garcia or some message
and they say well medium to tan or
something I give the William Bradford
you in name whatever and he went there
and but I don't know what becoming it
was usually the same Tavor on that yes
mm-hmm
and so you'd go there after making the
call and you sit there and and wait and
then he did walk in I said we just met
this tavern once that's on Canal Street
but pressure there was no series of
meetings in other words as I mentioned I
just I think I just went down her to
time excuse me two times on a type of
buildings mmm December and 67 and
and about three months later March of 68
mm-hmm so so you had only been there
twice paid you met Raul both times you
know one time he'd he'd went somewhere
else or something I'd call when he said
no he got to go with Birmingham I think
it was the last time well how did you
and I will get into Memphis did you come
up together
uh no we met at a motel or new rebel
thing was and I left Atlanta Birmingham
on about this this thing's been so long
going I really sucks I'm like Burma yeah
I think about March 29 to 28 not drove
slowly up to Memphis and now the FBI
contends I didn't do that I went back to
Atlanta and after heard Martin Luther
King was going to Memphis why I went
from Atlanta to Memphis after heard on
the radio in Atlanta but that's that's
incorrect and I think the fact is I
think the FBI has all my motel records
from March 29th until March the third
between Birmingham and Memphis but you
knew that you were supposed to meet Raul
in Memphis yes
on a certain day and you did that yes
and you were in the morning I know it's
a nighttime at nighttime the night
before
yes of Rania's the killing and and did
you spend the evening and did you go out
and have dinner did you what it what
happened uh no it's not I got rid of the
Leah rifle and that was a more I was
there that would been March April 3rd
April 30
Oh
did you ever sit down with authorities
and make a I guess what they call a
composite you know what I'm talking
about what police artists or something
and could make a picture of what Raul
might look like did you ever do that
what thought is me with with with the
police or with anybody added did you
ever sit down with a with a with someone
that could make a sketch or put together
a picture I'm never talking for ''tis
police or FBI anything I really don't
tend to but I had talked to committing
them they've never suggested any
composit but I showed him a picture and
described the picture where the
alteration should be made but I don't
like disgusting what's that old
committee because I think they're
operating sort of a private manner and I
don't think I should be going there too
much up well what I would think that now
you know you're talking about nine years
later and someone a lot of this is
dimmed in your memory as it would in
anybody's but when this thing was hot
when I mean back in the early days when
when you could recall Raul and see him
on the street he had known you never did
a sketch you never had a composite made
back in those days they was they really
wasn't interested um I think one of my
main problems is cases they've got a
circumstantial case against me this week
when they extradited me from London they
they had neck strap me quick and the
extra driving for first-degree murder
and doing all the shooting and
everything and the National now they
don't want to they don't want to alter
that because they can't under the treaty
in other words they can't try me for
aiding and abetting or anything like
that so they're more or less stuck with
their own testimony England so you think
their mind was made up when they got you
well had been made up they couldn't well
I don't know what there was any
apparently for extraditing someone
fraudulently or not but I think
I can see their legal point where
they've got stick with our story and you
stuck with your story your story hasn't
changed no I accept sometimes I'll miss
leader someone but I mean that's on the
record when I do that Bradford hew or
someone like that mm-hmm right I am I
wrote everything down on paper usually
when I first got arrested and get the
various attorneys in Haines and Percy
Foreman and I wrote a lot more for Percy
Foreman but he claims he lost he filed
somewhere he gifted John J hooker
that's a nice bill Tennessee attorney in
the tourney lost he file but I can't see
it lawyers losing her files like that
are kiddin but not when he goes in court
his word is taken above mine more
credibility although I claim I still
have him what files I had and he just
goes were recollection little black in
there
could be
trying to learn a little bit more about
what kind of a guy Raul might have
bended was he a talkative person did he
did he talk a lot they're really quiet
they were no it was there was not much
talking of course I don't talk too much
either on the outside so there was not a
lot of chatter if we wouldn't humor as
he didn't tell you jokes he didn't know
there was nothing like that it was what
was it very serious business we deal
with him but as people are on narcotics
pills and something they're kind of
quiet
yeah oh she might have been a user as
well as maybe a pusher yes mm-hmm
so he wasn't he just didn't run off at
the mouth much and when when you got
with him it was business yes and a lot
that a lot of that had to do with the
money I guess you were you were pretty
impressed with this money my maintenance
earn not only with him with it but with
all other associations uh was trying to
get passport I was more concerning the
passport than was money because uh I
want to get out of the country into out
of Canada this was before the shooting
yes you wanted to get you wanted to
leave leave this country huh yeah well I
wouldn't leave Canada I'd already left
this country and I was uh I wanted to
get fall away in Canada Australia so
mm-hmm
and you thought Raul was a man that
could do that before the strings get the
pass yeah I was promised passport the
first trip across the border and nothing
ever come with that mm-hm do you have a
lot of confidence in Raul's ability even
it was if it wasn't an underworld sense
no not not too much after you get after
your mislead a couple times but I was
trying various other ways get passports
and travel document it wasn't just in
one source fact is that's why I had
plastic surgery one time I was trying to
get a merchant seaman's papers in
California through the Coast Guard for
picturing
it was just one relying on one one
source did I let you down from time to
time uh we just wanted passports only
problems actually well but generally his
word was pretty good on mine yes and if
he said something you usually usually
got it there was never any well would
you take a hundred lesser anything I
mean bang it was there even it arguable
neck sometime mm-hmm he had it he
brought it out yes he playboy has quoted
a Percy Foreman as saying that you
invented Raoul to feed conspiracy
theories what do you say to it
I don't Percy for him he's been the face
was your friend wasn't well-known one
saves my friend he he's attorney uh
allegedly attorney my attorney for a
while but I first form and he's been
evolving a lot of unorthodox things why
he's been attorney I think he was died
here what about two years ago for the
hunt family huh
got some document I think he tried to
rival witness take a fall for something
similar did he didn't man and I wouldn't
get I don't want I wouldn't get mr.
Foreman too much credibility for two
reason not only because he's involvement
he's unorthodox legal operation but now
he's lost the file and I'm positive he
didn't lose it I think he's he gave to
William Bradford here somewhere
and when we had in habeas corpus here in
1974 we couldn't subpoena him because
he's a more than 100 miles of Memphis
and that's it was a limit of our
subpoena but we we invited him there to
testify under oath and he refused to
show up so I really can't see how he can
say things and newspapers and when comes
time to talk under oath why he all come
up some story you didn't invent ro no I
didn't I was a real human being at least
he was at that time he didn't know where
he was from or who he was connected with
didn't have any idea but expect me hi
come on in okay
now a lot of a lot of what you hope
might be beneficial to you was was
wrapped up in this name Rosen son and
determined that it was Randolph orwen
Rosen 'some and we've provided a picture
of him does he ring any bells or that is
he Raoul or can you tell whether it be
known OTT that no but I really shouldn't
talk about that because I think the
Committee on asked me about that and
I've give committee descriptions I can
mess them for I don't go too much about
what I told committee but I haven't
gotten descriptions and Jordan maps for
things to the nature would you feel that
Rosalyn might be a key in this somewhere
I would another one say that I think if
I were Rosen I'd sue playboy for slander
but something was false mm-hmm
they used his name right out in there
didn't it of course I'd have to get
council advice but I was he sue me so I
might civilly FBI or something but it
was a report wasn't there of roses of
being in Knoxville at the time of your
escape may already not still pay for I
wonder hey we don't know whether that's
true or not though no I you've had no
contact without apparently now you're
talking to the committee you apparently
have some faith in this committee you
don't view them as a threat necessarily
necessarily it's necessarily I mean you
think they might be on your side well
they've got a mandate to resolve these
cases and I don't I think that would be
on my side but
I mean I don't think they're going out
of their way to do me any favors yeah
that's cuz you're at a point I guess
where you don't know who to trust you
don't know really
oh I'm not certain about trusting anyone
that's I can tell anyone anything
because I'm ready to go to trial today
we could we had a trial if this
committee came in and said okay we found
Raul there he is
come look at him and you say yeah that's
him that's the guy that was with me down
there we would you be a stage witness
oh no I want 10 million state's witness
but see there's certain unresolved
things with the committee now mr. Lane
here well I have to discuss them with
him yes
but personally I don't I don't want to
speak as a Maughan lawyer but I guess
something be worked out with the
committee but I don't envy any state
witness and I don't think anyone can be
prosecuted this late that anyway because
they done committed the government
uncommitted their their case to the
extradition hearing in London so I don't
see how they can switch around now and
say it was some other way well there's
no statute of limitations or anything on
murderer I mean if if ryos the the
killer and they find while you still be
tried if they don't accuse me of it so I
don't know how they could then switch
around kill someone else and you would
be the main witness you would have to be
the main witness wouldn't you I won't be
a witness for myself hmm I'm not worried
about the prosecution with itself you
wouldn't come out and talk about Raoul
then and equipment uh no I there's
nothing that I can tell I mean I can
tell anything's my own words I could for
state with us you know I'm just not
interested minista